we begin with the latest on the
escalating crisis over ukraine in the
last hour the u.s president joe biden
has announced what he called the first
tranche of sanctions against russia for
its incursion in eastern ukraine the
american action follows a string of
punitive measures set out earlier by
european leaders biden says the
sanctions will target russian banks and
oligarchs and moscow's access to western
financing
so today i'm announcing the first
tranche of sanctions to impose cost on
russia in response to their actions
yesterday
these have been closely coordinated with
our allies and partners and will
continue to escalate sanctions if russia
escalates
we're implementing full blocking
sanctions
on two large russian financial
institutions
veb
and their military bank we're
implementing comprehensive sanctions on
russian sovereign debt
that means we've cut off russia's
government
from western financing it can no longer
raise money from the west and cannot
trade in its new debt on our markets or
european markets either
starting tomorrow and continuing in the
days ahead we'll also impose sanctions
on russia's elites and their family
members
they share in the corrupt gains of the
kremlin policies and should share in the
pain as well
because of russia's actions we've worked
with germany to ensure nordstrom 2
will not as i promised will not move
forward
dw correspondent oliver salad joins me
now from washington oliver what do we
make of the u.s president's response
well a very strong condemnation michael
he called vladimir putin's actions a
flagrant violation of international law
and referred to his speech that we heard
just yesterday saying that biden that he
believes biden that putin would go much
further that we might see a major
military attack on all of ukraine and he
also questioned the ukrainian right to
even exist so therefore what president
biden in the last days and weeks
announced that there will be sanctions
following uh russian troops crossing
into ukraine and and invading ukraine
this is what we heard here today and
some of them are blocking two russian
financial institutions cutting off
russia from the debt market so they
cannot refinance their sovereign debt
and then also targeting russian elites
families and this is actually the first
time
that president biden spoke about the
oligarchs and their connection to
vladimir putin so first tranche of
sanctions but it's also important to
point out here that there will be more
and can be more should vladimir putin
decide to escalate the situation further
what are people saying about how much of
an impact these sanctions will really
have
yeah that's really the big question
because of course this is not a surprise
for vladimir putin and for russia and
they've had a lot of time uh in thinking
about exactly this question it's
certainly a first step it's a dramatic
one russia sees now from the perspective
of the white house that they have to pay
a price for their actions it also leaves
the door open for vladimir putin because
there are more sanctions to come only if
putin decides that he wants to attack
ukraine further that he wants to move
his troops
beyond the separatist controlled areas
so there's still of course a chance for
him to steer back or to decide for a
diplomatic path but of course the u.s
expectation is
not as optimistic anymore
the problem is of course that vladimir
putin might have factored all that in
already
alvaro how likely is the u.s government
to launch further measures against
russia i suppose that has a lot to do
with what russia does
yeah that's just right michael it really
depends on what's going to happen next
just to just keep in mind there will be
no military intervention um ukraine is
not a nato member so we're talking about
further sanctions and that really
depends on the question will russia move
their troops beyond the separatist
controlled areas will it be a
full-fledged invasion will it move
beyond the dawnbest will will russia
attack kiev will they conquer all of
ukraine all those questions are
circulating right now but again no
matter what what they do there will be
no military actions taken so certainly
the the the measures that the united
states and the nato partners have are
limited the concern is then then also
that belarus might be integrated into
the russian federation and that there
are even further and stronger
implications in the month and perhaps
years to follow
soviet union 2.0 uh dw correspondent
oliver salat in washington dc thank you
earlier vladimir putin raised the stakes
saying he now recognizes the entire
territory of two breakaway republics in
eastern ukraine as independent the
russian president made the announcement
a day after recognizing the donensk and
luhansk people's republics as
independent states the latest move could
herald a russian push further into
eastern ukraine across the current front
line into territory currently held by
ukrainian forces here's what vladimir
putin had to say
we've recognized the donetsk
which means we've recognized all their
founding documents including the
constitution
and the constitution defines the borders
of the donetsk and luhansk regions at
the time when they were part of ukraine
and i emphasize this
that all the contentious issues will be
resolved in negotiations between the
authorities in kiev
and the leaders of these republics
unfortunately at this stage we
understand that this is not possible
because facilities are continuing there
and could intensify
dw correspondent matthias berlinga is in
kramatosk in eastern ukraine uh mathias
explain to us the significance of this
latest announcement by the russian
president
this of course raises the stakes and it
makes a russian incursion much more
probable uh than if he had contented
himself to the actual
borders of these controlled territories
the separatist controlled territories um
these uh self-proclaimed republics
control about a third a fourth to a
third of the territory of these two
uh uh terri of these two districts of
ukraine um including both capitals
district capitals but uh and and some
areas around but vast uh parts of these
districts are under ukrainian government
control and he now makes claims to these
territories this makes of course a
military action to gain control of these
territories more probable there has been
some confusion about this yesterday
however this is not unexpected and as we
heard yesterday that putin basically
claims the whole of ukraine as part of
russia
how are people taking this where you are
in in the donetsk region
we've seen in this region
an escalation of violence during the
fast past five days and the lead up to
this decision
mostly what we've seen is shelling from
the separatist side onto villages
controlled by the ukrainian army and
also onto military posts but a lot of
civilian villages as well
so
people here are of course scared of an
escalation have been scared of an
escalation for some time this of course
makes it even more probable that this
escalation will really come and it will
happen here in this area today i went to
one of these villages and the people
that have been basically sitting in
their basement for for for five days now
they're really scared of what's
happening many people are escaping right
now people mostly are escaping from the
front line from these villages that are
being shelled but of course all over the
place and here in the city that 70
kilometers from the line um fear is
growing
fear scared and also no doubt looking to
see how their government is reacting can
you tell us how the ukrainian government
is responding to the threat from russia
up until now the ukrainian government
has been very measured very restrained
they have of course said that this does
not make sense to them that these
territories are ukrainian by
international law and that they will not
seed these territories uh but they are
also trying not to contribute to the
escalation the kremlin these shellings
they
according to the ukrainian the
assessment of the ukrainian government
these shellings had uh the purpose of uh
luring ukraine into a response that
might then be used as the pretext for an
incursion ukraine is trying to uh avoid
this but of course if
the the attacks from the separatist side
uh separatist side and the russian army
that is now stationed there will
increase you the ukrainian army that is
stationed all along this line will
somehow react
matthias berlinger in kramatosk many
thanks
dw has been speaking with people on the
streets of kiev to get their reactions
to this latest russian move
we're really
afraid about our democracy about our
country about our freedom
we really hope that russia will be
stopped
but regarding whole situation
we think that
lots of restrictions should be done
before it's all
completed i think we try to
to show our own word that we are really
good country and we deserve to be free
so we are living in a hard time for
ukraine and a lot of people are
experiencing fear every day like going
to bed and waking up we don't know where
actually where exactly we're going to be
like in danger like when
kg will be like in real danger for us i
think ukraine generally protesting every
day just by appreciating our culture and
history like every day is like a fight
for us to survive another day to be in
uh
like united country oricia luzavich is
head of the ukraine forum at the foreign
policy think tank chatham house in
london and joins us now welcome to dw um
what was your reaction to russian
president putin's speech last night in
which he questioned ukraine's right to
statehood
well uh last night's putin's address to
russian nation was very much in line
with his
quasi-historical essay his issues last
summer where he exactly says ukraine is
an artificial state that has been
created by these puppets you know it's a
puppet regime so basically it's in line
of denying ukraine a statehood saying
it's not a real country it's quite um
humiliating for the thousand-year-old
history of ukraine and i think that it
was in a way um a quasi-declaration of
war on a ukrainian state
he's essentially saying that ukraine is
not legitimate and yet at the same time
he is acknowledging accepting embracing
the existence of these breakaway
republics as in fact independent states
what do you make of the logic there
well the logic is that of course ukraine
exists only as an extension of a russian
civilization and it can only exist as um
either in full uh coherence with russian
governance the russian or autocratic
kleptocracy and orthodoxy or otherwise
if it rebels against these kinds of
values it's a non-ukraine that is being
manipulated by the united states poland
austro-hungarian you name it so putin
basically says if it's ukrainians who
love russia they are true ukrainians all
other ukrainians on ukrainians
do you expect russia to stop at sending
troops into luhansk and donetsk
honestly i think russia keeps full
deployment
around ukraine's border it has made new
crossing into ukrainian territory from
the east uh of course unobstructed
because the border is being controlled
by russia at that point uh but um i
imagine that the deployment will
continue and we may see uh that russian
troops will move into a closer proximity
to existing line of conflict uh between
right now currently guarded by the proxy
groups and ukrainian armed forces i want
to make sure i understand what you're
saying are you saying that regardless of
how this unravels over the next coming
days or weeks that you see a sort of a
permanent deployment of russian troops
in ukraine
well absolutely they're already
preparing to build military bases and
this is
uh signed in the this agreement of
treaty with these quasi republics that
will permit russia to permanently
station its troops similar to what we
see already happening in belarus and
today uh we hear russians are not
retreating from belarus and they
continue to threaten the capital of
ukraine from the north auricia luzevic
from chatham house in london really
appreciate your time and your
perspective
nato has condemned the escalation of the
crisis over ukraine and russia's
recognition of two breakaway regions as
independent states the alliance's
secretary general jen stoltenberg has
described it as the most dangerous
moment in a generation he said russia
has not stopped planning for a
full-scale invasion of ukraine and
warned against ongoing provocations in
the east of the country stoltenberg
added that nato would continue to
provide ukraine with strong political
support
this is a crisis created by russia alone
we commend ukraine for its restraint in
not responding to russia's repeated
provocations
we stand in solidarity with the
ukrainian people and its government
allies are united in their full support
for ukraine's sovereignty
and territorial integrity within its
internationally recognized borders
the 27 european union member states have
unanimously agreed on an initial set of
sanctions targeting russia the eu's
foreign affairs chief joseph borrel says
the measures will affect members of
parliament and other individuals
involved in deploying troops and that
the package will hurt russia
the great violations
russia is committing
will not go and answer it they are not
going to answer it we are strongly
united in this front
and we will
raise
the level of senses substantially
according with the russian behavior
because many question marks
are pending
on these critical moments
russia's escalation of the crisis over
ukraine has brought a flood of
condemnation from western leaders
president putin's decision to recognize
two breakaway regions of eastern ukraine
as independent states has also prompted
punitive sanctions the toughest at this
stage is likely to be germany's decision
to halt the key nordstrom 2 gas pipeline
project
this has been built to bring russian gas
to europe but still needs the go-ahead
from german regulators which chancellor
olaf schultz now says has been suspended
indefinitely
german chancellor schultz on his way to
announcing a key foreign policy decision
to halt the highly controversial north
stream ii pipeline in response to
russia's recognition of two separatist
regions in ukraine
the situation today is fundamentally
different
and therefore in view of the latest
developments we have to reassess the
situation also with regard to north
stream too
north stream 2 aimed to transport
russian gas directly to germany under
the baltic sea its construction was
finished last year and was pending
regulatory approval
for a long time both russian and german
leaders including schultz in the past
had defended the project but it had
plenty of very vocal enemies
ukraine as a start because it undercuts
its own pipelines
but also the us and various eu countries
concerned it would give russia too much
power and leave europe vulnerable
those countries welcomed tuesday's
decision with ukraine's foreign minister
calling it morally politically and
practically correct
big words of support towards the german
chancellor who had previously been
criticized for being too vague on the
north stream 2 pipeline